bonsoir a tous très heureuse de vous
retrouver émission largement consacré ce
soir à l'audition d'agnès busin elle
était très attendue vous avez pu la
suivre en direct l'ancien ministre de la
santé face aux députés et à ses
contradictions souvent ému la voix
éteinte
elle est revenue sur la pénurie des
masques sur la destruction des stocks et
surtout sur son intuition sur l'ampleur
de l'épidémie on débrief dans un instant
le fond comme la forme avec nos invités
on parlera aussi de la vague verte après
les municipales bordeaux lyon strasbourg
qu'est ce qui va changer concrètement
dans les villes qui ont basculé dans
l'escarcelle d'europe écologie les verts
emmanuel macron lui aussi est dans le
vert du temps virage sincère au tournant
opportuniste on en parlera à la
présidentielle se jouera-t-elle sur
l'écologie enfin enfin dans ma journée à
l'assemblée thomas des prêts nous
parlera de l'attrait des territoires 20
députés sur 22 c'est beaucoup élu aux
municipales ont choisi de quitter leur
mandat à l'assemblée le travail des
parlementaires serait-il moins
intéressant qu avant réponse à la fin de
cette émission voilà donc pour le
programme c'est parti attaque sévère on
y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
à peine remise de sa cinglante défaite
aux municipales la voilà donc à nouveau
sur le gril
agnès buzyn a donc répondu aux questions
des députés pendant plus de quatre
heures ce soir elle s'est défendu pied à
pied pour démontrer que contrairement
critique elle avait bien anticipé les
choses
elle n'avait pas sous-estimer le risque
et elle s'est même défendu sur ses
confidences polémique au journal le
monde
elle s'était vendue au fonds d'avoir eu
quelques états d'âme écouter sur
l'article du monde
d'abord ce n'est ni un interview est
encore dans une déclaration sinon
j'aurais relu ses propos ces verbatim ne
ment jamais été soumis et encore moins
une déclaration est ce que ces propos
sont vrais ou pas bien des tenues ou non
oui on était jeune
sincèrement monsieur le rapporteur
[Musique]
j'avais passé une journée point table
j'étais très fatigué on m'accusait sur
les réseaux sociaux de n'avoir rien vu
et c'est tout le contraire
voilà c'est tout le contraire on va en
parler avec vous ce soir julien aubert
bonsoir merci d'être là vous êtes député
les républicains de vaucluse vous nous
direz si les explications les quatre
heures d'explications d'agnès besoin
vous auront convaincu ce soir bonsoir
arnaud benedetti a vite vous accueillir
à nouveau sur ce plateau on va analyser
avec vous la forme
vous êtes spécialiste de la
communication communication de crise ou
pas réussi vous nous direz tout à leur
rappelle que vous dirigez la revue
politique et parlementaire mais celui
qui va ouvrir cette émission ne va pas
déroger à la règle c'est stéphane
blakowski qui va nous rappeler le
contexte dans lequel est intervenu cette
longue audition ce soir si j'ai bien
compris c'est une forme de descente aux
enfers pour agnès buzyn
[Musique]
bon sang messieurs bonsoir stéphane si
j'ai bien compris ce soir si j'ai bien
compris myriam faut quand même bien du
mérite à julien aubert pour faire de la
politique quand même parce que là on
voit ce qui est arrivé agnès buzyn ça
devrait à peu découragé tout ce qu'ils
disent mais la politique c'est tellement
simple s'est fait prendre parce que l
ess bien voilà quand même une personne à
qui tout réussissait dans l'existence un
brillant des études elle devient
professeur de médecine a à peine 40 ans
en 2011 il est nommé président de
l'institut national de la recherche
contre le cancer par décret du président
de la république nicolas sarkozy quand
même en 2016 et les nommer à nouveau sur
décret du président à la tête de la
haute autorité pour la santé cette fois
le président c'est françois hollande
oui tous les présidents l'adorent
vraiment sa sézanne pour eux ça ne
pouvait mieux démarrer
à tel point que en 2010 est bavard c'est
carrément emmanuel macron qu'ils vivent
tout le monde aime bien on la nomme amis
de la santé elle a fait la preuve de ses
compétences
je pense qu'en ce moment de sa carrière
nice besoin de dire c'est pas si
compliqué la politique je vais être à
peu près compétents et puis on fait
quand même mieux que que tous et
bateleurs sur leur estrade sauf que
voilà
elle était élue meilleure ministre
par la nourriture dispositi qu'en 2018
et puis et puis et puis tout a basculé
le jour où elle s'est dit que plutôt que
de rester à milan mais la santé elle
allait essayer de devenir maire de paris
il a donc quitté le ministère
et d'ailleurs ce jour là quand elle a
quitté le ministère elle pleurait si
vous ne vous en souvenez pas on regarde
une grande émotion à ce moment là on
imagine qu'elle pleure parce qu'elle
quitte ses équipes avec avec lesquels
elle a travaillé deux arrivées une
petite larme quand on se quitte à bout
de deux ans passés ensemble mais
finalement elle a donné une autre
version de ses larmes dans une interview
qu'elle a donnée à ariane chemin une
journaliste du monde avait dit que si
elle pleurait c'est parce qu'elle savait
depuis le début que l'épidémie allait
prendre de l'ampleur et qu'en quittant
le ministère
elles anticipé le fait que les élections
seraient certainement une mascarade et
donc elle a été jusqu'à enfoncer le clou
en disant qu'elle avait en plus prévenu
le président par sms le 11 janvier et
qu'elle avait aussi averti le premier
ministre le 30 janvier c'est cette
interview qui crée une onde de choc et
qui d'une certaine façon faire exploser
voilà comment la bombe derrière des
gagnants d'aujourd'hui agnès buzyn après
tout ce brillant parcours ce brillant
avenir politique et son principal regret
diba son regret c'est d'avoir décroché
le téléphone pour parler à ariane chemin
donc journaliste au monde parce que ce
j'aurais été vraiment au bout du rouleau
c'était après sa défaite au premier tour
et donc elle a eu envie de vider son sac
sans mesurer toutes les conséquences que
ça aura qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce
qu'on le fait elle a craqué bah voilà en
gros la craqué en fait je vous ai fait
remarquer m en la regardant la
télévision passe moment faut pas trop la
secouer
agnès buzyn comme on dit elle et remplis
de larmes donc tout le monde témoigne de
50 à rennes chemin fait son article dit
que agnès buzyn était en larmes au
téléphone quand cédric villani l'a
appelé après le premier tour il a dit
étonné qu'elle était effectivement aussi
en larmes anna cabana fait un grand
portrait dans le jdd où disait que ça
avait commencé l'entretien par une crise
de larmes
donc oui ça va pas très fort en
politique il ne faut pas montrer ses
faiblesses c'est un adage conseil c'est
plus compliqué pour agnès buzyn voilà
c'est vraiment la super super christ que
quand on lit des articles sur agnès
buzyn en ce moment c'est ce qu'ils
veulent faire court 10 le choc le crash
et ceux qui aiment bien les lieux
communs 10 descente aux enfers chemin de
croix dont vraiment n'en sort pas donc
je sais bien qu'en ce moment les les
politiques n'ont pas forcément la cote
dans l'opinion est quand même là
pourquoi est-ce que c'est assez raide ce
qui les attend ça nous rappelle à quel
point ce que le vit ça peut être violent
la politique ou si un jour myriam je
vous dis j'en ai marre d'être un petit
commentaire
je veux faire preuve de courage et me
lancer en politique vous n'hésitez pas à
vous de me gifler mais vous me gifler
matin à toute volée comme ça que je
redevienne lucide ainsi qu'avec moi en
attendant pour cette idylle à la vie
c'est un tiers les amours attire les
amis un talent merdassou fait de la
politique je pense que la proportion des
emmerdes
elle commence à croître considérablement
comme on l'a vu aujourd'hui pour agnès b
un homme est d'aider type peut être
avant de voir le sujet pour qui barrent
synthétiser un peu ces quatre heures
d'audition
ce contexte il faut rêver forcément il y
pèsent ils pèsent sur cette femme et
même sur des députés oui il pèse sur
cette femme mais parce que des visages
vous l'avez finalement dit en creux dans
vos commentaires
ce n'est pas une politique c'est
quelqu'un qui a été une excellente élève
dans l'administration de la santé à
laquelle on n'a rien à reprocher dans sa
trajectoire professionnelle et tout d'un
coup elle s'est convertie en politique
elle a été converti en politique par le
choix qu'a fait le pr qu'on fait les
premiers le premier ministre le
président de la république de la nommée
au ministère de la santé
et c'est quelqu'un qui a découvert tout
d'un coup la dureté de ce monde et qui à
découvrir surtout la dureté aussi de la
relation à l'opinion publique ce qui est
quand même quelque chose qui structure
la relation du politique dans son
existence quotidienne et c'est bien
évidemment cette difficulté à laquelle
elle s'est confrontée notamment en plein
milieu de cette crise on va sur le fond
et je vous donne la parole juste à
contribuer il faut aussi des vrais
politiques ont durci au cuir solide au
cuir tanné que retenir de ces quatre
heures d'audition d'agnès b d'un temps
fort compilées par clément méric
je vous invite tous deux a levé la main
droite et dire je le jure je le jure en
étant entendue devant vous je souhaite
pouvoir m'expliquer vous m'interrogez
sur ma première conférence de presse
je pense être la seule ministre de la
santé européennes avoir pris la décision
de faire une conférence de presse
aussitôt
vous me posez la question du stock de
masques
alors non je n'ai pas la connaissance du
courrier du 26 septembre et ne vais pas
adressés c'est donc une responsabilité
de lagence santé publique france que de
vérifier d'acheter entre les gérer les
stocks stratégiques de l'état c'est sa
mission
vous nous dites ya des réunions chaque
mois chaque semaine avec les directeurs
et sur un sujet aussi essentiel jamais
au cours d'une de ces réunions est
évoqué le fait qu'on a plus de stocks
stratégiques de tous les produits et
vous le découvrez en janvier 2020 ce que
vous nous dites à ma connaissance ce que
nous avons mis en place au ministère de
la santé depuis le 10 janvier est sans
commune mesure
en tous les cas en termes d'anticipation
avec ce que j'ai vu notamment dans les
autres pays
vous ne pouvez pas dire que je n'ai pas
anticipé le 7 février
je donne nous donnons l'accord à la dgs
pour commander des masques des lunettes
des gants des chaussures des charlottes
du soluté hydroalcoolique alors que la
pandémie est déclaré quand même le 11
mars
cinq semaines après donc vous pouvez pas
dire qu'on n'a pas été réactif
je quitte le ministère le 15 il n'y a
pas eu de cas nouveaux depuis neuf jours
aucun cas nouveau en france
moi j'estime que j'ai fait mon travail
de préparation du système de santé et je
le jeu quitte le ministère parce qu'il
ya un contexte politique et que je suis
comme vous je pense qu'il faut un moment
se présenter devant les électeurs sur
l'article du monde
d'abord ce n'est ni un interview et
encore moins de déclarations
vous l'avez compris nous sommes est ce
que ces propos sont vrais ou pas même
avis tenue ou non où il souhaitait
sincèrement monsieur le rapporteur
j'avais passé une journée pouvant table
j'étais très fatigué on m'accusait sur
les réseaux sociaux de n'avoir rien vu
et c'est tout le contraire je me suis
battu pendant un mois donc que j'ai dit
au monde ce jour-là c'était arrêter de
dire que j'ai rien vu j'ai tout vu j'ai
tout vu j'ai préparé cet article laisse
penser que je n'ai pas préparé
c'est pour ça que je voulais m'expliquer
devant la représentation nationale
voilà arrêtez de dire que je n'ai rien
vu j'ai tout vu j'ai tout préparé je
viens aubert vous sortez de cette
audition quatre heures d'audition et de
questions à l'ancien demi de la santé ce
qu'elle vous a convaincu oui non oui
dans le sens où il ya une forme de
sincérité j'ai trouvé c'est quelqu'un de
comment dire que c'est du concerné de la
dignité dans un moment compliqué pour
elle donc j'essaie de me mettre à sa
place
il ya une volonté de mettre sur la table
ce qu'elle savait ce qu'elle ne savait
pas que c'était appréciable
là où elle ne m'a pas convaincu c'est
sûr la logique de l'argumentation c'est
à dire que si elle a vu et il a tout
préparé dans ce cas là pourquoi ça a été
aussi mal préparés ensuite et donc des
responsabilités je ne peux pas moi parce
qu'elle se défausse un peu sont très
différents sur l'administration elle se
défausse vous soyez une station quand
elle dit bah écoutez moi je n'étais pas
au courant enfin ses amis de la santé
alors je peux le comprendre qu'elle me
dise dans le dossier il n'y avait rien
sur les masques ça pose un vrai problème
fonctionnel ou organisationnelles on se
dit finalement heureusement qu'on avait
un médecin comme ministre de la santé
qui avait donc des intuitions
sauf que moi je ne cherche pas un
lanceur d' alerte au ministère de la
santé je cherche quelqu'un qui à partir
des informations qui remontent de
l'administration prend les bonnes
décisions or ce qu'elle nous dit tout la
base son argumentation c'est de dire en
réalité moi je n'avais peu
d'informations qui venait dans l'armée
de dieu merci j'avais dix huit heures
j'avais facebook j'avais google et donc
ça m'a permis de prévenir les autres
mais moi je cherche pas mon sens d'
alerte
je cherche un ministre et je sais lui
l'arrivée de julien borowicz bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes le vice-président de
cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire vous êtes médecin de
profession vous n'avez pas raté une
miette de cette audition je rappelle que
vous êtes député la république en marche
de la loire qu'est ce que vous répondez
à julien aubert au fond il ya une forme
de paradoxe buzyn j'ai eu l'intuition
mais j'ai pas pu agir ou j'ai agi mais
ça ne suffisait pas manifestement il a
prouvé la pénurie de masques sa personne
n'a la nuit il alors il n'y a pas un
paradoxe d'abord la pénurie de max n'a
perdu pénurie de match devait arriver je
crois qu'il faut quand même reprendre le
contexte
fais attention quand même a toujours ce
passionné sur cette histoire de masques
évidemment qu'il ya eu un problème
une problématique de masse n'oublions
pas quand même que les recommandations
c'était les personnes soignantes et les
personnes malades
les recommandations officielles celles
oms port du masque aux déboires
uniquement et c'était ça et les masses à
sa a fluctué poussé en médecine il faut
quand même être très humble très modeste
je vous rappelle que la contamination
interhumaine était la ministre l'a dit a
été annoncé est relativement tardivement
karine lacombe nous a expliqué aussi que
lacombe infectiologie nous a rappelé que
très tardivement on a su que les
personnes étaient contaminante
avant même que des signes arrive ce qui
était assez exceptionnel soit une
maladie jusqu alors c'était un cri le
matin c'est que ce qu'on entend à
prendre la commission c'est que depuis
en 2018 en tire le signal d'alarmé
l'administration en disant il ya un
problème de maths faut refaire le stock
et que on se rend compte en 2020 que
finalement passé pas spécialement chrono
coronavirus que c'est une surprise
ok très vite s'ils n'ont pas suivi le
film parce que ces techniques en avril
2010 est au début du quinquennat a léché
fontafie tech et 714 millions de masques
oui c'est qu'il nous faut un stock en
cas d'épidémie à 1 milliard mais on
n'était pas finalement très loin mars
2020 donc trois ans après le début de
l'épidémie
10 117 millions de masques à 600
millions de masques qui ont été détruits
elles sont expliquées un très longuement
destruction à partir de 2018 mais elle
dit qu'elle n'était pas au courant c'est
ça qu'on apprend dans cette audition ni
par la direction générale de la santé
nih par santé publique france il ya des
masses qui ont été détruits il ya des
masques qui était inutilisable mais elle
ne le savait pas est-ce que c'est pas un
problème c'est un problème et c'est ce
que j'ai prêté dans madame est question
c'est à dire que
la question de cette commission enquête
c'est aussi de voir l'avenir et c'est de
se dire comment fonctionnent les agences
aujourd'hui il y avait alors d'abord il
y avait une lettre qui disait un
milliard de masques un milliard de
masques si on a 30 % de la population
qui est atteinte d'une pathologie virale
on n'a jamais atteint ce 6e ce niveau là
et quand même une note ça s'ils arrivent
en octobre 2018 pour dire il faut
reconstituer ce stock alors il ya une
note qui arrive en septembre 2010 8,7 ce
fameux courrier de monsieur bourdillon
qui dit faux un milliard de masques 26
septembre
qui nous dit faudra un milliard de
masques bon sauf que le 3 octobre il
nous dit il ya 650 millions de masques
qui sont à détruire il se trouve que
c'est ce monsieur là qui a depuis un
certain nombre d'années avait en charge
la gestion de ses stocks
la vérification normalement de ses
stocks et nous annonce que 650 millions
de masques doivent disparaître
elle a quand même contacté le directeur
général de la santé en demandant que
deux justement et nous a dit qu'il
verrait qu'il avait contacté la ministre
sauf que manifestement il ne l'a pas
feuille locale a fait de joe corvo elle
a fait le maximum c'est ça avant que
j'aimerais qu'elle avait fait le maximum
je dis simplement que qu'est ce qui dit
le 3 octobre parce qu'on s'est
arquebouté sur la lettre du 26 septembre
mais je me répète on est en train de
s'arc-bouter sur les masques j'écoute
votre question tout à l'heure oui tout à
l'heure vous nous parler de la stratégie
coréenne enfin oui la ministre la
ministre utilise le terme de stratégie
en temps réel et vous nous dites
benjamin vit encore et on est des
masques pour tout le monde voilà je vous
rappelle donc pas ce que vous aviez
l'air très intéressés par ces stratégies
coréenne brise et vous vous focalisez
sur les masques je vous rappelle que la
stratégie coréenne est basé sur les
masques oui et l'application stop
qu'ovide que vous avez et les têtes
elle était là et les tests par la
politique
vous avez été conditionné que chaque
dent si vous voulez mais c'est un
travail dense y est et on va essayer de
prendre parce que les gens parce que la
pénurie de sauver mary de masques à une
pénurie de sang
rien à voir ce qui se fait encore un
baiser leti est ce qu'on est pas ce que
c'est stop que vider les plus strictes
encore et la la séparation presque un
espèce de mur comme ça entre
l'administration la haute administration
dgs santé publique france et le
politique
oui mais c'est bien le problème
d'ailleurs et c'est ce qui est apparu
lors de cette audition ce qui peut à la
fois servir et desservir la ministre en
l'occurrence la servir parce que le
sentiment qu'on a à l'écouté c'est
qu'elle est dépassée par la complexité
d'une organisation administrative avec
des et selon enchevêtrés où vous avez
des services ce qui d'ailleurs ne
communique même pas entre eux parce que
quand même il ya une réalité c'est que
et qui ne communiquent pas en direction
d'un minispace que finalement le
directeur général de la santé a
manifestement reçu une note qui n'a pas
fait suivre à sa ministre en tout cas
c'est ce qu'elle a dit mais la protéger
[Musique]
la santé publique
oui mais là oui ça c'est vrai elle
assume et en tout cas la responsabilité
de son directeur général de la santé
donc on a le sentiment qu'on ait fait
elle est dépassée par son administration
par la complexité de son administration
et c'est bien la difficulté c'est que
justement elle donne le sentiment d'être
dépassé et qu'est ce qu'on aurait dit
qu'est ce qu'on attend d'un politique ce
qui est tout à fait naturel en attend
d'un politique c'est qu'il maîtrise son
administration m
on a des essentiels n'a pas séjourné
pouvant talent qu'elle était
trouvez moi il explique alors les 18 la
bioéthique la retraite elle était
submergé de deux cas là le problème
c'est qu'elle avoue que l avoue qu' elle
n'est pas en capacité de gérer tous ces
dossiers donc elle fait preuve d'une
certaine faible
d'une certaine manière elle avoue sa
fragilité sa fragilité à dominer la
situation
donc c'est léger défense personnelle qui
peut créer si vous voulez parfois un
sentiment d'empathie parce qu'elle
semble extrêmement fragile en
l'occurrence et si on le sent très bien
d'ailleurs même les parlementaires me
semble-t-il ont intériorisé cette
fragilité n'y en élisant relativement
ménagers y compris les parlementaires
d'opposition mais en même temps ça pose
un problème essentiel vis-à-vis de
l'opinion publique vis-à-vis de
l'opinion publique s'est dit
est ce qu'elle était à ce poste est-ce
qu'elle était véritablement en mesure
d'assumer ce poste compte tenu de cette
fragilité qu'elle semble démontrer enfin
julien aubert et vous aurez la parole
pour la défense ces choses bien je pense
qu'à une ligne de défense qui est la
fragilité qu'elle utilise aussi parce
que ça permettait peut-être d'éviter des
questions trop compliqué ça n'est pas
parce qu'elle dit qu'elle n'était pas au
courant que c'est vrai il faut encore le
vérifier
et évidemment on va pas rester longtemps
avec santé publique france qui dit c'est
pas moi c'est bercy le des le salomon
qui disent pas moins c'est bercy là
nathalie c'est le chacun se refilent la
patate chaude
et puis il ya quand même des questions
sur lesquelles l'affaissement ne pas
comprendre moi je vais poser la question
parce qu'on a eus l'audition du
président du professeur raoul ce qui a
expliqué que en réalité il y avait une
déformation profil du bea des conflits
d'intérêts sur les très bons voilà ceux
d une des influences de laboratoires
pharmaceutiques je lui ai fait
l'historique je dirais de discovery qui
a notamment été pondue par un comité
scientifique est paré acting où son mari
a joué un rôle si que une bande de gens
qui se connaissent mais vous pensez que
c'est le coeur du problème
oui franchement oui je vais vous dire
pourquoi sud parce que 90 je vais
d'abord ne méprisez pas le sud c'est
quand même la moitié du pays si vous
permettez moi j'en fais partie du ca
bien mais pas le mien le deuxième non
deuxièmement à points quand même c'est
que en quoi enfin cécile dieu pourquoi
s'est il vraiment de marge
alors je vous dis pourquoi ce test un
nom parce que la tour de contrôle c'est
le comité scientifique c'est lui qui
établit la stratégie sanitaire de la
france c'est lui qui lance ne savons
loïc et scientifique puis le comité
internet ou sur les mêmes hommes qui
lance le projet discovery avec le thé
sur le traitement et vous avez un
infectiologue célèbre qui est
spécialiste ceux ci qui vous dit on à
pas et qu'on n'a pas écouté sur la
stratégie on m'a pas écoutée sur le
traitement et vous découvrez que les
animosités personnelles et que l âme
administrés
du professeur raoul à la vérité c'est à
dire est-ce qu'on a écarté un institut
qui t'a fleuron français alors qu'il y
avait peut-être des stratégies
alternatives
si on veut ou alors on considère la
stratégie qui a été suivie était la
meilleure mais excusez moi qu'on parie
que l'allemagne attend dé moi là on
n'est pas sur la question du traitement
on est testé massivement
pourquoi est ce que dans ce cas là
lorsque elle décrète que seule paris et
lyon peuvent faire des tests pourquoi
pas marseille
non j'ai d'abord revenu sur wii sur
cette question là des conflits
d'intérêts et ensuite au fond est ce que
il ne faut pas une réforme dans
l'administration sanitaire donner plus
de pouvoir aux politiques
alors d'abord sur le conflit d'intérêt
je comprends qu'elle n'est pas vraiment
saisi la question parce que dans votre
argumentaire grandiose qui tient pas là
discovery
ils ont étudié l'hydroxyde rockin ils
ont étudié leur md ben oui mais quoi non
non on est on pas étudié le protocole
raout n'ont fait un truc sic la rouquine
azithromycine et on a fait des missions
déjà des antilles raout alesi mais
j'aimerais qu'on avant de jean-louis
messages importants et ils ont étudié
dans discovery lorraine désir oui c'est
gildas bons qu'ils ont étudiés donc le
rennais divers pour ceux qui nous
regardent cette l'autre molécules à côté
de la chloroquine avec des accusations
derrière allait terminer parce qu'on
s'éloigne un peu notre sujet bah oui
mais bon je réponds finatel et donc ils
ont étudié et même des civils de la même
manière que l'hydroxyde chloroquine dans
la même étude et les deux études arrive
aux mêmes conclusions leur haine des
civils comme les proxys chloroquine
n'ont pas d'intérêt thérapeutique
le rapport bénéfice risque n'est pas bon
je vous ai écoutés donc j'aimerais bien
que vous laissiez me parler jusqu'au
bout donc voilà donc il ya une égalité
de traitement dont je ne vois pas
pourquoi on irait chercher un conflit
d'intérêts tout a été testé juste une
chose par rapport à ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure sur la ministre la
ministre n'a pas dit j'étais en
faiblesse la ministre dit le 3 octobre
je reçois une note de santé plus fatale
le dgs reçoit une note de santé publique
france qui dit
il y à 650 millions de masse qui ne vont
pas mais tout le stock de médicaments de
produits contre les les risques
nucléaires et tout est à 0 tout est
périmée etc
et qu'est-ce qui se passe le 6 octobre
je crois que cette autant le dgs prend
les mesures pour recommander un stock
donc chacune des parties donc je crois
que la ministre aussi à juste titre
faisait confiance à son dgs
elle n'a pas dit qu'elle était en
faiblesse forte heureusement ce qui est
important c'est la façon dont elle est
perçue à travers cette audition et le
sentiment qu'on a quand on les coupe
c'est que quand même lé déplace à vide
assez des plats dépassé par encore une
fois une organisation qui est
extrêmement complexe et dont elle ne
paraît pas tout à fait maîtrisé le
fonctionnement ce que vous avez senti
favorable à remettre sur la table au
fond on parle de l'organisation de
l'hôpital là il faut repenser
l'organisation de l'administration de la
santé
est ce que c'est normal que le ministre
ne soit pas au courant de cette note
pourquoi la direction générale de la
santé ne lui transmet pas est ce que
c'est normal cette impuissance à
laquelle on assistera que le professeur
delfraissy nous l'a dit en audition il y
avait besoin d'un conseil scientifique
pour essayer de faire travailler aussi
les agences entre elles on a fait une
mission d'information avec mon collègue
dharréville sur les in plein de files à
l'époque sur les implants dans les
dispositifs médicaux et on s'est rendu
compte de la même chose c'est-à-dire
qu'on avait des agences qui avait fait
du travail mais de manière isolée
souvent sans se parler et avec bah
justement la petite faille qui n'ont que
vous dites qu'il faut changer quelque
chose donc donc je dis qu'il faut
coordonner la ministre déjà tout à
l'heure le disais je pense qu'elle avait
tout à fait raison pour le coup d'avoir
une agence de crise vraiment et on
l'avait avec lui ce fut un temps nagel
et déjà avoir alors qu'on a trois
semaines d'audition des conclusions
organisationnel
une entreprise intuition collectivités
ont pu faire des masques alors que je
n'aime pas si vous voulez les
fonctionnements téléologique c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui vous avez sur des
buts c'est ça oui en fonction du bit
aujourd'hui vous avez quand même un état
patent d'inorganisation des problèmes
criants des gens qui se renvoient la
balle avant d'aller vers les français en
disant écoutez on a compris le problème
voilà nos solutions ne faisons pas mine
de passer parce que je sais bien qu'il
ya des questions qui embête
mais il suffit de consulter des réseaux
sociaux pour réaliser que les français
se posent et dernier tour de table parce
que ce débat s'achève l'audition a duré
donc forcément il a peu écourtée at-elle
encore un avenir en politique a renommé
17e sp d'un selon vous c'est une
question à l'accueil est toujours très
difficile de répondre on dit
généralement qu'en politique on n'est
jamais mort mais en l'occurrence quand
même n'est pas une peu comme elle n'est
pas une politique si vous voulez n est
pas d'une politique au sens où
finalement son arrivée dans la politique
est récente
j'ai tendance à penser que plus tôt sa
carrière politique est derrière elle
mais ce n'est que est-ce qu'on a sonné
ce n'est qu'après sentiments et en
l'occurrence on l'a vu bien en tout cas
elle a vécu
disons depuis quelques mois disons un
parcours qui relève d'un véritable
calvaire en semaine à la fois en tant
que ministre et en tant que candidate à
la mairie de paris ni à revers c'est la
société civile celle expertise d'un
médecin aussi oui enfin se dire la
société civile vous savez c'est un terme
très bas taux utilisé
bon je sais pas parce qu'on vient de la
société civile qu'on est meilleurs
moments brillants et puis finalement
politiquement des cas eu un conflit des
cas un obstacle est surmonté la laquelle
les dires des gens qui viennent de la
société civile et qui font très bon
politique vous avez des gens qui ne
souhaitent ici qui ne sont pas faits
pour ça il faut pas que la politique
selon après ça dépendra tout dépendra
des conclusions de cette commission
denquête si on s'aperçoit par exemple
que la menti je vous dirais que ça sa
carrière politique est terminée
si en réalité à la fin on s'aperçoit
qu'en réalité effectivement elle avait
fait bien fait son travail et palaiseau
elle est d'un beau
reichel junas borowitz wii est simple
vous souhaitez qu'elle reste elle va l'a
fait partie de la macro ni je pense que
là une place importante au corps à jouer
avec nous alors à quel niveau je ne le
sais pas mais avec nous et évidemment
mais c'est vrai que le fait de la
société sil et j'en fais partie c'est ce
gros avantage de dire que on peut sortir
de la politique on a un métier derrière
c'est parfois cruel la politique merci
merci d'être venu sur le plateau de lcp
vous restez avec nous julien aubert on
va parler maintenant de de cette vague
verte et de ses conséquences sur
l'agenda politique du gouvernement
strasbourg bordeaux lyon on a pris les
victoires les plus emblématiques avec
cette question à quoi maintenant va
ressembler très concrètement la vie des
habitants dans lesquelles les europe
ecologie les verts a gagné aux
municipales c'est ahmed tazir qui s'est
plongé dans les programmes d euros et qu
ils sont des visages du changement cette
vague verte qui a déferlé sur les
grandes villes françaises
a lyon c'est le candidat grégory doucet
qui a remporté les municipales devenant
le nouveau maire de la ville l'écologie
n'est pas l'ennemi de l'économie
elle est sa meilleure alliée
grégory 12,7 tourner la page gérard
collomb et veut prendre rapidement des
mesures pour répondre à l'urgence
climatique réduire la place de la
voiture lutter contre la pollution de
l'air il souhaite une ville 100% marche
à bhl et cyclables des repas à la
cantine 100% bio et avec 50 % de
produits locaux à bordeaux
pierre hurmic a mis fin à 73 ans de
règne de la droite cela faisait 25 ans
qu'il tentait sa chance
moi je plantais l'écologie depuis
quelques années j'ai connu des airs
fastueuse quand ce soir j'ai connu aussi
des basses eaux
mais je me suis toujours accroché à
l'étang persuadé qu'un jour je serai en
phase 1b les bordelais sait les
bordelais ce soir j'ai la conviction il
ya car l'ambiance cas dans cette cour du
palais rohan j'ai vraiment pensé à
d'être parfaitement en phase avec les
aspirations des habitants de bordeaux
le nouveau maire veut un débat sur les
dangers de la 5g la voiture aura moins
de place pour stationner circuler pierre
hurmic veut propulser la pratique du
vélo et n'exclut pas de supprimer une
voie à la circulation automobile
avec près de 42% dans une triangulaire à
jeanne bars et guillon a balayé ces
l'adversaire à strasbourg
il faut désormais compter avec
l'écologie il faut désormais compter
avec la soif de justice sociale il faut
désormais compter avec l'inspiration
revendiquer à une démocratie citoyenne à
strasbourg dans le centre ville la
nouvelle maire promet encore plus de
pistes cyclables et l'interdiction des
véhicules diesel dans la ville dès 2025
une autre mesure l'interdiction des
terrasses chauffées chez les commerçants
trois nouveaux maires au projet
écologiste ambitieux des mesures qui
provoquent aussi de sérieuses
inquiétudes dans les milieux économiques
elles nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
barbara pompili bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous à vous êtes présidente
de la commission du développement
durable ici l assemblée et député la
république en marche de la somme est à
côté de vous car karima delli
bonsoir la députée européenne europe
ecologie les verts qui a triomphé 1 dans
plein de grandes villes en france aux
municipales lyon bordeaux strasbourg
poitiers tours besançon grenoble c'est
beaucoup plus que vous n'espériez ce qui
fait dire à julien bayou secrétaire
secrétaire nationale d'europe écologie
les verts que ce n'est pas une vague
parce qu'elle ne va pas refluer il parle
de tournant vert il parle d'un effet de
cliquet il pas un peu vite un nom
d'abord il faut relativiser parce qu'on
est très conscient que l'abstention
était record est donc cette crise
sanitaire aussi a montré qu'on avait une
crise démocratique mais surtout
institutionnels mais les français ont
soif d'écologie et donc ils ont volt est
réellement pour des listes et des des
acteurs qui vont faire pourquoi parce
que tout simplement une mauvaise dix ans
pour retourner la courbe des
températures mais surtout nous sommes la
première génération qui subissons les
effets des effets de gaz à effet serre
nous sommes la dernière génération à
pouvoir agir avant qu'il soit trop tard
donc pour vous c'est une exigence qui
les met pas qui va se renforcer avec le
temps et bien sûr ça n'est pas au fond
un moment non c'est pas un moment parce
que justement ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que partout en europe et notamment
en france
la première priorité des français c'est
l'écologie et donc leur bien-être
au fait ils vont pas attendre la
révolution verte ils vont la faire
et ils veulent absolument avoir des
acteurs qui font evin tant mieux si des
villes comme bordeaux grenoble lyon soit
aujourd'hui verte mais vous allez voir
que ça va aussi s'accélérer parce que
les gens veulent envoyer un message très
clair ils veulent d'avoir des villes où
l'on respire
ils veulent des cantines bio ils veulent
surtout léguer une planète vivable leurs
enfants on a vu les programmes vous avez
versé une petite larme ou vous
l'ancienne europe ecologie les verts
quand vous voyez ce qui est en train de
se passer
personne n'imaginait bordeaux ans est
inconcevable il ya encore deux trois
jours vous dites page et j'ai fait une
erreur j'aurais dû rester dans ma
famille politique d'origine non parce
que au contraire ce que montrent ces
élections c'est que l'aspiration
écologique elle dépasse largement un
certain nombre de clivage est donc que
des villes entières se tourner vers
l'écologie tant mieux me fais moi
j'avais fait europe ecologie les verts
comme l'avait fait parce qu'en plus vous
tombait mal parce que karim et moi on
s'entend très bien parce qu'on imagine
très bien et ce qui est ce qui est
important c'est que à un moment puisse
mettre en place des politiques
écologiques
moi je regrette que le mouvement
politique auquel j'ai adhéré et pas
senti ça et pas poussé plus que ça des
quelques on préfère toujours l'original
à la copie ça veut dire que c'est les
verts qu'ils ont latéraux le savez mieux
que personne donnant une élue non parce
qu'on avait on se doutait que les vagues
qui viendraient verte arriverait dans
les grandes villes
maintenant moi je suis élu de picardie
en picardie on n'a pas eu la vague verte
parce que il ya encore un besoin de que
qu'une partie de la population
ce prêt prennent ces principes et puis
les les intègre et aujourd'hui c'est pas
le cas au fond parce que votre bilan en
matière d'écologie mais pas nul
au niveau du jeu de macron quand on
regarde y'a quand même l'abandon de
notre dame des landes la montagne d'or
repasse ittihad et mesurer à la main sur
les transports je vais la rénovation
thermique
il ya des choses et vous n'en êtes pas
crédité comment vous l'expliquez non
parce que à un moment il faut avoir un
discours clair il faut être cohérent et
c'est vrai qu'il ya peu et vous n'étiez
pas là jeudi à la pontaise
il ya peut-être eu cette peur d'aller
jusqu'au bout et je crois que sur
l'écologie et on l'a vu et quelque part
la crise du coc vide a permis aussi de 2
à beaucoup de monde de réfléchir à tout
ça ça nécessite d'y aller
et de faire les investissements qu'il
faut parce que beaucoup de gens ont
encore cette tendance
malheureusement terry mais qui existe à
croire que si on fait de l'écologie ça
va aller contre l'économie et compte le
social c'est exactement inverse
mais par contre ça mérite non julien
baer ça mérite d'être anticipé d'être
préparé là aujourd'hui on ya la
fermeture de fessenheim
moi je regrette énormément qu' on n'est
pas donner plus de visibilité à ces
territoires depuis longtemps parce que
depuis longtemps c'est que cette
centrale va fermer mais cms de france et
l'inde que ça n'allait pas être le cas
et plutôt que d'anticiper de préparer le
territoire de préparer les gens de
préparer les acteurs eh bien on s'est
retrouvé avec une situation ça a dû être
gérée en deux ans de temps et donc ça
c'est pas c'est pas bien et donc
l'anticipation c'est la base même de
l'écologie et on vous anticipez et
europe écologie va trop loin trop vite
trop fort non
europe écologie a fait quelques
alliances que je trouve dommage et qui
ont empêché de mettre tout le monde
autour de la table il faut arrêter
d'opposer les élytres non pas avec les
socialistes n'ont mène alors non parce
que là il faut que ça circule ces
municipales elle se résume pas à la
prise des grandes villes puisque c'est
vrai que la droite a gagné en nombre de
villes le plus grand nombre mais mais
mais mais quand même ça doit vous
interpeller à droite
est ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
de laisser passer un train donc d'abord
sur la vague 230 civils plus de 38
habitants on parle de 10 villes
conquises par europe ecologie les verts
certaines ayant en cogestion contre 77
par la donne est donc là dans lesquelles
deuxièmement deuxième axe avec la
participation qu'on connaît et les
triangulaires
ce n'est pas pour autant une vague en
revanche c'est vrai ça traduit pour une
certaine sociologie dans les grandes
villes
à mon avis un besoin d'amélioration de
la qualité de vie que la crise de l'aco
vide à accentuer parce que les gens se
sont rendu compte qu'ils vivaient dans
des univers minéraux maintenant il faut
pas confondre besoin d'écologie et
besoin d'écologisme c'est à dire qu'on
peut très bien avoir une écologie qui
n'est pas celle qui est prônée par mes
deux collègues par exemple prenons année
parce que tout le reste et fessenheim
moi je pense que si on veut lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique dans
l'urgence on doit décarbonés
l'électricité l'économie bon eh bien ce
n'est pas en fermant des usines
qui produisent une électricité
décarbonés qu'on lutte conte le
réchauffement climatique le même même
quand on a les centrales vétustes le
alors d'abord elle était tout à fait en
état de fonctionner d'ailleurs affirmé
avant mais le sujet si vous voulez
d'ailleurs on va fermer on va en fermer
d'autres puisque le pouvoir en marche
peu enfermé ils ont beaucoup parlé donc
si vous permettez un petit peu de
malaisie à les développer parce que je
ne sais pas comme je sens que la parole
ne va pas me revenir
donc si vous voulez un moment donné il
faut être conscient que le vrai écologie
c'est celui qui dit moi mon objectif
c'est le co2 on peut pas lutter contre
le nucléaire et lutter contre le co2 un
moment donné il faut choisir l'avion
parce que les gens qui travaillent et
pasquet centrale quand vous dites
l'écologie et l'économie ne sont pas
compatibles baril et ensuite vous karima
delli parce que vous souriez et en même
temps après on n'a pas du tout déclaré
la guerre au nucléaire il ferme fait
c'est vrai mais franchement on sent bien
pour lui c'est encore une énergie
d'avenir
vous savez c'est comme pour tout nous ce
qu'on veut c'est mettre tout le monde
autour de la table et essayer d'avancer
ensemble
on n'essaie pas de monter les uns contre
les autres le sujet de la lutte contre
le changement climatique c'est pas le
sujet de l'électricité
aujourd'hui l'électricité est décarbonée
pour une grande partie
aujourd'hui la lutte contre le
changement climatique elle se joue sur
les transports elle se joue sur le
logement
elle se joue sur l'agriculture bus
desservant j ai se joue au ballon des
mains bien et me voient l'argent mais
bien évidemment où va l'argent ailleurs
où va l'argent sur wilson i'm no no no
no no no no nano sur le budget de
l'écologie combien de milliards d'euros
puisque vous êtes présidente vont sur
l'électricité carbonée décarbonée est ce
que vous dites que c'est pas la priorité
mais attendez si vous croyez qu'on leur
politique écologiste n'est que sur
ministère d'écologie vous vous trompez
complètement non les aujourd'hui le
problème du nucléaire
on va pas passer notre soirée là dessus
mais sur l'électricité
la question c'est pour sonder soin de
mettre tous nos oeufs dans le même
panier
on a vu que le nucléaire avait ses
limites et notamment sur la crise qu
vide à cause du fait qu'on n'a pas pu
faire les les inspections de sûreté des
centrales on va devoir les faire plus
tard résultat on va voir des risques en
approvisionnement alors que si on avait
d'autres types d'énergie nous n'avait
pas mis tous nos oeufs dans le même
panier
on n'en serait pas là et le nucléaire ne
diffuse pas de gaz à effet de serre ou
peut donc j'en ai énormément quand même
c'est alors est claire et polluant et
dangereux la ville vous voulez vous
d'autre problème vous voulez réagir
là-dessus puis ensuite on va avancer sur
ya plein de trucs sur la convention
citoyenne ailleurs tout d'abord moi je
suis contente qu'on ferme fessenheim
parce que fessenheim a été conçue à 50
ans lancé ya quarante trois ans mais
surtout c'est que nous on est une
génération où on ne nous a pas demandé
notre avis tu dire un sas et j'ai dit
nous sommes peut-être que vous avez dans
l'emballement faisons mais je vais vous
dire pourquoi je suis pas d'accord avec
vous assez simplement de mon évolution
non plus n'étaient pas nés lorsqu'on a
créé effet selon m
et pourtant je peux vous dire on a on a
fait plein de l'innovation le concorde
ont la ferme et voyez départ est grave
c'est intéressant parce que ça amène à
la question des associations du citoyen
à la décision politique donc ça s'arrête
à celle en actualité le président de la
république je vais revenir sur sa donc
voyez fessenheim pour moi il ya
deux-trois plus il ya trois grands
problèmes et vous êtes député vous
devrez lire les rapports notamment de l'
agence de sécurité
on a vu que sur fessenheim l' agence de
sécurité dis quoi il ya quatre fois plus
d'incidents dans cette centrale qu'au
niveau national
donc ça veut dire quoi c'est comme vous
savez on a eu carnot bildt chénéville
qu'un accident nucléaire due à une
catastrophe humaine on a eu fukushima dû
à une catastrophe naturelle et fesnam
c'est que la lie les deux mais je vais
venir sur sept une urgence climatique et
vous pensez-vous
gens qui voyaient leur zone sismique et
égale gravité pour les gens ensuite par
rapport à votre co2 parce que ça génial
chez vous le nucléaire énergies propres
alors énergie ben non c'est pas la
solution du pont moi je résume à canon
mais ça c'est une fausse bonne idée qui
n'aimait pas clair il ya des bonnes
idées pour simplement la raison suivante
c'est que d'une part ça nous coûte un
fric monstre c'est vrai alors je vous
proposerai en mai mais sans moi je sais
combien de temps et moins 100 milliards
d'euros
c'est sûr que ce serait bien si vous
êtes dans le rapporteur des crédits elle
la met fin à un débat budgétaire
problèmes et les citoyens beaucoup les
citoyens karima delli 146 propositions
seront reprises sur 149
il va y avoir des référendum ça veut
dire que l'agenda politique des six
prochains mois
ça va être l'écologie je moi je fais
attention à ça parce que pendant trois
ans on a eu le gouvernement de la parole
pas des actes et moi je suis très fâché
sur ça parce qu'on est en train de
perdre du temps nicolas hulot a claqué
la porte en disant trois choses la
france était at-elle été leader dans la
baisse du co2 non est-ce qu'on est
arrêté l'artificialisation des sols non
est ce qu'on a fait justement on est on
s'est battus au glyphosate
sinon non mais non vos journaux et non
et moi je le vois même au niveau
quand je compare que vous ne lui fait
pas confiance non alcoolisées pour moi
je n'ai à certains à dire notamment
certains députés me sens tellement
minorité c'est je le sais sur la méthode
et les glam et que ce sont les écoles
la méthode c'est comme le grenelle de
l'environnement extraordinaire outil de
démocratie ça finit par quoi le connaît
mais alors nommé grenelle de
l'environnement quand on est tous les
acteurs autour de la table on trouvera
des solutions
vous étiez très clair j'espère je pose
répondre quand même allez-y c'est pas de
faire une idéologie néo marxiste high
tech gildas et emploi et qui détruit les
coloniser des antilles préservation des
paysages la conservation d'un patrimoine
naturel ont par exemple sur
l'officialisation des sols je vais vous
rejoindre j'ai même j'ai même proposé
quelques années l'interdiction des
surfaces commerciales au delà d'une
certaine donc je suis d'accord avec vous
parce que ç'a un impact quand je vois si
vous voulez qu'on dépense 400 dessins
sur l'écologie pour lutter contre le
nucléaire vous transformez le nucléaire
en éoliennes axe n'a pas d'impact et je
vous dis comble de la biodiversité c'est
des vrais sujets mais le chômage en est
un aussi dans votre famille pour le
débat sur le climat
oui le 9 mars et jay yamaha discussions
m donc si on considère c'est une vraie
urgence
alors dans ce cas là on arrête de partir
sur des chemins de traverse et surtout
on arrête de penser une écologie sans
l'homme
c'est ce que je reproche au plus mal
d'écologie humaniste parce que vous ne
réussirez pas la transformation au pas
de charge en oubliant les hommes les pc
drop vous disais est ce qu'il ya une
convention citoyenne qui a travaillé
pendant près d'un an comme bien encadré
non mais ça ressemble plus au congo
alors là non de ségolène royal en
séquentiel et des maisons cambadélis en
scène la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire
je parle de l'encadrement pas des
citoyens excuses à présenter le mot de
la fin est vrai pourquoi j'ai à cette
convention préfectoral d'europe écologie
les verts à base d'interdiction et de
réglo mais je vais arrêter
mais moi j'ai eu beaucoup de contacts
avec les membres de la convention
citoyenne pour le climat faut pas les
prendre pour des idiots
ce sont des gens des citoyens comme vous
et moi qui ont bossé qui se sont
renseignés qui ont rencontré tout le
monde y rencontrer tous les acteurs non
non ne prenez pas les gourmandises et si
vous prenez pas les gens pour des
imbéciles pour tout son travail est déjà
engagée sur le passage à l'acte en qui
ont fait des propositions et ce qui est
intéressant c'est quand on s'intéresse
au sujet et bien effectivement les
propositions qu'on fait ce sont des
propositions audacieuses et moi je me
suis engagé auprès d'eux pour porter ces
propositions et pour faire en sorte
qu'elle faisait des suites ils se sont
constitués en association ils vont nous
aider à le faire et ça c'est bien parce
que ça prouve que quand on met tout le
monde autour de la table on peut avancer
ans et on sera là vraiment vérifier tout
ça sur ce plateau est ailleurs merci
infiniment d'avoir un job d'un débats
écourtés audition d'agnès busin oblige
c'est la fin de ce ça vous regarde merci
à vous d'avoir été là mais demain
[Musique]